we're gonna start with breaking news for
you from North Korea which fired two
suspected short-range missiles overnight
South Korea's Joint Chiefs of Staff say
they were launched from the northwestern
part of North Korea and they are
thoroughly analyzing the evidence five
days ago Kim Jong Un's regime test-fired
other projectiles that landed in the sea
after complaining about the pace of
nuclear talks with the u.s. Elizabeth
Palmer is monitoring this unfolding
story from Beijing Elizabeth good
morning good morning the launch happened
about three and a half hours ago and as
you say the South Koreans were analyzing
the early evidence at first they said
they were simply projectiles they've
since confirmed that they were
short-range missiles now those missiles
were launched from an undeclared base
that US intelligence nevertheless does
know about on the west side of the
Korean Peninsula they went on to
splashdown in the Sea of Japan this is a
second launch in less than a week and a
clear message to the US that the North
Korean leader Kim jong-un is getting
impatient over those stalled talks that
would offer North Korea sanctions relief
in return for denuclearization the last
round of talks with President Trump
collapsed in February image of the last
launch on Saturday show North Korean
leader Kim jong-un observing multiple
rockets apparently being tested and also
what appears to be a missile leaving the
launch pad north korea has since
described these as regular defensive
military exercises but they're clearly
designed to amp up the pressure now
north korea has given the united states
a deadline of the end of this year to
come up with a deal John who is with
Palmer in Beijing thank you